sans ce public on passe tout de suite à
notre second débat débat de société avec
un anniversaire aujourd'hui c'était il
ya 40 ans presque jour pour jour le 30
septembre
1981 le sénat a voté l'abolition de la
peine de mort samia des chiens sur l'âge
et 1er du projet de loi portant
abolition de la peine de mort
nombre des votants
288 nombre les suffrages et 30 septembre
1981 après quinze heures de débats les
sénateurs ont fait leur choix pour
l'adoption 161 contre 126 le sénat a
adopté
par ce vote historique
la peine de mort est définitivement
abolie en france et pourtant la partie
n'était pas gagnée le sénat
majoritairement de droite est alors
réputé hostile à la mesure défendue par
un gouvernement de gauche lorsqu'il
monte à la tribune robert badinter
s'efforce de placer le débat au-delà des
positions partisanes
l'essentiel je l' ai déjà dit je ne
reprendrai pas ce que j'ai évoquées
devant nous l'essentiel demeure ailleurs
il est en effet un problème de
conscience et seulement si la conscience
de chacun c'est comme souvent ce qui va
dicter le vote sur un sujet société elle
aussi sensible car en réalité le sénat
n'est pas hostile mais surtout très
divisés sur la peine de mort à tel point
que la commission des lois chargée de
donner un avis sur le texte n'arrive pas
à dégager de position claire paul girot
qui préside alors cette commission
décide donc de s'en remettre à la
sagesse des sénateurs à chacun de forger
sa décision lui même en entrant dans
l'hémicycle ne sais pas ce qu'il va
voter je veux faire tourner vers mes
collègues jarry côté je ne peux que vous
réciter ce qu un président de cour
d'assises 10 s est juré quand ils vont
rentrer en salle de libération nous
devrons non aucun compte
des raisons pour lesquelles vous
prendrez votre décision elle ne vous
pose qu'une seule question qui contient
l'immensité la difficulté de votre
devoir
elles ont une intime conviction
une liberté de votre totale et des
débats sans aucune limitation du temps
de parole au bout de trois jours de
discussion les sénateurs se sont laissés
convaincre dette lire définitivement la
peine de mort en france j'ai pris
voilà dans ce débat qui est notre débat
de société on va prendre le temps c'est
le privilège de luxe que nous avons dans
cette émission sens public deux à la
fois se tourner vers le passé et aussi
savoir que c'est un combat qui continue
en france et ailleurs j'accueille avec
grand plaisir maître henri leclerc
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes avocat
évidemment faut-il le dire président
honoraire oui parce que vous avez pris
votre refus il ya quelques quelques
semaines c'est une nouvelle vie qui
commence vous êtes président d'honneur
de la ligue des droits de l'homme cécile
coudriou bonsoir soit présidente
d'amnesty international bien vous avouer
seafrance évidemment évolué au fil du
bon soir vous êtes historien vous avez
publié raccourci dernières paroles
stupéfiante est véridique avant la
guillotine c'est chez prisma
édition évidemment matthieu croissandeau
notre éditorialiste est toujours à mes
côtés on vient de voir ce reportage qui
nous projetait 40 ans en arrière maître
leclerc comment vous avez vécu ces
journées de l'automne 1981 jusqu'à
l'abolition jusqu'à ce que soit votée à
l'assemblée puis par le sénat c'était
pour des gens comme moi qui depuis
depuis que je t'ai avocats déjà c'est à
dire depuis déjà longtemps depuis 55
c'est un moment donne une émotion
intense bon d'abord set c'était mon ami
robert badinter qui étaient là mais en
plus ça c'est en deux temps qu'on se bat
et là dessus si vous voulez que moi je
vais tout lu moi j'avais une double
expérience m'avait indiqué j'étais à la
fois voc avocat et président d'honneur
des droits de l'homme en fait j'avais
une expérience de militant
c'est à dire que j'allais partout et
j'étais également militant d'ailleurs
dollar l'association française contre la
peine de mort deux colloques en coloc
dresde meeting de réunions quelquefois
les réunions on arrivait y avait pas
grand monde en fin d'article
et puis et puis j'ai
j'ai été confronté directement comme un
local j'ai une chance incroyable
c'est à dire que dans ces périodes j'ai
été en a demandé six fois la peine de
mort contre maintenir et six fois il n'a
pas était c'était des moments de à la
fois de 2,2 terrible angoisse et puis le
2 g de grande joie mais le et alors ce
jour là ex-collègue d'abord j'avais une
première émotion très forte ça je le
dire c'est le jour chez plus cartes sur
table je crois françois mitterrand avait
dit je suis contre la peine de mort ma
conscience je crois aux forces de
l'esprit et serment et il avait dit
qu'il abolirait c'était dans ses
propositions m'enfin bon il zappe le
dirai et puis l'a nommé mandataire comme
garde des sceaux oui j'étais rassuré
mais en même temps je dirais assuré à
l'assemblée nationale pas grand chose à
craindre compte tenu de la majorité et
on a vu des gens comme comme chirac
comme seguin qui voter l'abolition de la
peine de mort c'est important et puis
après il ya eu au sénat avec le rapport
de monsieur j rôle l'aider
non mais tu es moi je jure que je dois
dire
et je me souviens très bien de
l'angoissé était pas je suis pas venu où
ça mais j'ai qu'on écoute et la radio en
permanence est bon ça va ça a été voté
s'était changée après tout la suite
cécile conneries vous étiez adolescent
ch et est bachelière au moment des
élections mais j'ai commencé mes études
préparatoires j'avais déjà la fibre
militante donc je dois dire que pour moi
aussi ça a été une grande émotion ça ne
me paraissait pas forcément atteignable
si vite et donc ça a été quand même
rapide après l'élection de françois
mitterrand et donc j'ai encore un
souvenir très vivace notamment de ce
célèbre discours non seulement le
discours assemblée nationale bien sûr
mais également le discours la plaidoirie
plus exactement des robert badinter
lorsqu'il l'a rendu si concrètes cette
terrible peine de mort en disant que
c'est une lame qui coupe en deux un
homme vivant et ce sont je pense des
mots qui ont vraiment fait une
différence donc j'ai une admiration sans
bornes sans borne pour maître badinter
et pour le courage politique aussi de
françois mitterrand je pense que c'était
absolument essentiel que la france
qu'elle est bien trop tarder car c'était
tout de même le dernier pays de ce qu'on
n'appelait pas encore l'union européenne
à l'époque mais la commission européenne
a enfin abolir donc dans un pays qui se
voulait la patrie des droits de l'homme
s'était quand même pas tout à fait
cohérent donc effectivement pour pour
moi c'était pas encore bien sûr associé
amnesty international car c'est plus
tard que j'ai adhéré mais sachez que
amnesty international en fait
commencé ce combat pour l'abolition
universelle dès 1977 donc avant même
cette abolition en france nous étions
rapprochés de robert badinter et lorsque
nous avons réuni cette conférence
internationale la conférence de
stockholm qui a donné lieu ensuite à la
déclaration de stockholm est bien
évidemment robert badinter était déjà à
nos côtés et je pense en toute humilité
ce cas ci ne s'agit pas de moi mais du
mouvement que je représente que ça a
largement inspiré robert badinter il le
dit encore aujourd'hui qui s'est senti
très proche de la façon dont on avait
abordé les choses c'est-à-dire de
demander très vite une abolition
universelle
on y reviendra sur l'abolition
universelle dans le débat vous nos fils
signé je vous dis la france était en
retard par rapport à d'autres pays de
l'est européen est ce qu'il ya eu une ou
plusieurs entre guillemets occasions
manquées d'autres moments dans notre
histoire finalement la tête de mort
auraient pu être aboli oui bien sûr ce
qui s'est passé en 1981 est
l'aboutissement d'un très long combat
des abolitionnistes alors on a
complètement oublié mais par exemple en
1795 la dernière séance de la convention
vote l'abolition de la peine de mort
mais je vois là à compter de la
publication de l'appel général donc
évidemment pour les années de la
révolution du consulat et l'empiré c'est
un petit peu les calendes grecques et ça
restera sans effet et puis alors après
il ya des grands abolitionniste des gens
comme lamartine comme victor hugo la
tribune qui vont défendre la peine de
mort face à l'abolition de la peine de
mort venir en 1848 la peine de mort est
abolie en matière politique mais pas en
matière criminelle ce qui amène victor
hugo a prononcé un discours absolument
magnifique dans la qualifie il demande à
ses collègues d'aller plus loin en
expliquant que la peine de mort est le
signe spécial et éternel de la barbarie
ils demandent l'abolition pure simple et
définitive de la peine de mort mais il
n'est pas entendu et puis alors le grand
rendez-vous raté c'est au début du 20e
siècle entre 1906 et 1908 figurez vous
qu'un ancien président du sénat est élu
président de la république sous la
troisième république ce sont les
parlementaires qui ne désigne le chef de
l'état armand fallières quête un avocat
abolitionnistes alors il a peu de
pouvoir en tant que président mais il a
le droit de grâce il grassi
systématiquement le président du conseil
n'est autre que clemenceau qui est
également abolitionniste la majorité
supprime les crédits du bourreau les
crédits qui servait à financer des
exécutions donc
factuellement il n'y a plus de peine de
mort mais elles existent encore en droit
et dont c'est empêcher qu'elle soit
vraiment laissé la sphère soleilland
vous avez raison bien sûr la faire
sonner dans c'est un fait divers
sinistres mais qui va être monté en
épingle par la grande c'est l'âge d'or
de la presse populaire d'après
s'illustrer et là on a un exemple assez
extraordinaire d'utilisation d'un fait
divers sordide meurtre d'une adolescente
par un personnage sinistre meurtre
sordide qui va me remonter si vous
voulez l'opinion en faveur finalement de
la peine de mort et une partie des
députés qui à la limite et bien auraient
voté l'abolition change d'avis et lorsqu
en 1908 il ya vraiment un vote sur la
loi qui aurait pu abolir la peine de
mort est bien renversement de majorité
la peine de mort n'est pas abolie en
1908 il faudra attendre 1980 henri
leclerc en 1980 sur sur ce point précis
de la peine de mort parce qu'il vient
d'être élu françois mitterrand mais est
ce que il a derrière lui une majorité de
français non choisie à 63% les nous
savons bien que nous nous battons contre
une majorité incontestablement favorable
apple dock elle a presque toujours été
là pas été pendant quelques années après
elle les revenus et les mots d'origine
au nivellement salle à la majorité cdh
assez la matière mitterrand fait preuve
d'un courage politique tout à fait
remarquable le monde et il faut le dire
il a décidé l'abolition de la peine de
mort aie aie aie aie il a nommé robert
badinter ce qui était bon prix et ce
prix ne s'est pas qu'il n'avait pas les
compétences pour être garde des sceaux
mais en même temps c'était très
symbolique de nommer robert badinter qui
avez vous le savez obtenu le fait que
patrick henry ne soit pas condamnée à
mort par une plaidoirie effectivement
exceptionnel on va écouter tiens
justement plusieurs fois non robert
badinter l'ancien garde des sceaux se
souvient de ces procès où il plaidait
mais avant l'abolition de la peine de
mort écoutez
chaque fois qu'elle est un grand crime à
chaque fois c'était à même vague de
demandes
de mise à mort et moi qui plaira ces
périodes bien les affaires où étaient en
jeu réellement la vie à la mort
de la cuisine je ne bénéficiait pas
d'une popularité
remarquable au contraire je peux vous
dire que lui et
des abords du palais était rempli d'une
foule très abondamment vraiment un
document mettant des
français il a raison le times rappelle
un choc quand vous êtes dans une affaire
où la peine de mort était demandée où
seul l'avocat général termine que je
demande la peine de mort c'était
toujours terrible alors là vous êtes
dans un air comme surtout contre et avec
encore jeune mais on est dans un état
assez épouvantable et surtout il ya
quelque chose d'extraordinaire c'est ce
que robert badinter exprimera comme je
n'avais pas su l'exprimer d'ailleurs en
plaidant après je vais copier une fois
quand il dit quand il dit vous allez
couper cette maman de chacun des jurés
paris et moi je disais simplement jeu
dès qu'on arrivait là moi je pensais au
coût de l'homme qui était derrière moi
c'était c'était terrible si vous voulez
alors on en parle et on 18 secours tous
et vous en parliez pendant la
plaidoirie avec votre client est ce que
c'était un tabou de parler de ce cette
visibilité ne s'était pas tabou fallait
reparler
prudemment vous savez les clients
étaient dans une situation lips et
s'était penché vers des gens qui avaient
fait les choses bien et donc il était
dans une situation très très difficile
les piles avocats ont le se trouve dans
la situation dans laquelle on est
toujours en phase d'un client qui a fait
les choses difficiles et dont il faut
enfin moi du moins comme avocat je pense
que robert aussi il faut faire intégrer
cette personne pour pour appeler des
poëles il faut d'un certain côté il va
falloir un moment faire que celui que
tout le monde regarde comme si c'était
un monstre on réussisse à en faire un
être humain c'est et quand la peine de
mort tant couru quand on fait cet
exercice on est bon l'avocat est étendue
mons et c il faut qu'ils transmettent
cette horreur qu'il a il faut qu'il la
transmette aujourd'hui m'ont jugé et
c'est très difficile bon il fut un temps
où les jours et jugé seul est ce qu'elle
est extrêmement curieux s'est créé un
vieux greffière la cour d'assises de
paris dont le père était déjà greffiers
en 1900 m'avait montré les registres et
quand les greffiers les jurés jugé seul
il y avait eu ouvrir peine de mort
acquittement acquittement peine de mort
c'est à dire qu'il n'y avait pas de demi
mesure et
c'était été mais là mais là les
dernières affaires ou des idées aux
accusés ont été condamnés à mort sont
les affaires quelquefois horrible à même
le dernier conviendront c'était c'était
terrible mais en même temps dans
laquelle parfois se pose est quand même
le problème de l'innocence je pense à
nos çi quand on lit le livre de gilles
perrault on est quand même un peu
impressionnés de savoir que cet homme a
été condamné à mort matthieu
croissandeau ne le combat de robert
badinter qu'on a entendu à l'instant il
s'est évidemment nourris de son
expérience notamment d'un d'un procès
précis celui de claude buffet et roger
bontems c'était juin 72 les yeux robert
l'inter l'avocat de roger bontems
l'époque à roger bontems il est détenu
avec tous deux buffets et ils font une
tentative d'évasion avec une prise
d'otage où ils prennent notamment un
gardien une infirmière en otage et des
deux otages vont mourir c'est claude
buffet qui va les tuer mais les deux
hommes sont jugés et robert badinter est
l'avocat de roger bontems et il va me
raconter dans deux livres d'avoirs
l'exécution qu'il est qu'il écrit un an
plus tard et puis va reparler dans
l'abolition qui écrit encore quelques
années plus tard sur son sur son combat
il s'en veut beaucoup robert badinter
pas ce qui pour lui est un principe de
base qui était que si on n'a pas tué on
n'est pas exécutée et qu'il dit avoir
mal mesuré la pulsion de mort qui
avaient à ce moment là dans le tribunal
et et roger bontems alors qu' il est
prouvé qu'il n'a pas tué et condamné à
mort complices et il forme un pourvoi en
cassation qui a rejeté et plus pilou
démocratie par exactement et pompidou ne
le gracie pas et cette histoire alors
c'est pas le début de l'engagement de
robert badinter contre contre la peine
de mort mais sait on le sent une l'écrit
lui-même ce qui va ce qu'ils valent
habité longtemps avec une forme d'ironie
de l'histoire ou de tragédies de la vie
c'est qu'ils se retrouvent à trois là où
avait été jugé bon temps quelques années
plus tard pour prendre la défense de
patrick henry donc pour le coup qui
était accusé du meurtre d'un enfant et
il va découvrir il le raconte très bien
aux parlementaires il s'en servira
d'ailleurs dans son discours actions des
nationales qu'on a vu et revu et qu'il
faudra encore voir et revoir il raconte
à ceux qui qui nourrirait quelques
espoirs qui est une vertu pédagogique et
la peine de mort que dans la foule qui
criait à mort buffet avoir bon temps
en 72 il y avait patrick henry qui sur
un enfant quelques années plus tard vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure m leclerc le
il ya toujours enfin il ya souvent une
une majorité de français dans les
sondages d'opinion qui se prononce pour
la peine de mort regardez cette dernière
étude c'est le baromètre fractures
françaises qui a été lancé depuis un peu
plus d'une
zen d'années il y annonce et septembre
2020 55% des personnes interrogées qui
répondent oui qui demandent le
rétablissement de la peine de mort et
puis si on regarde la tendance cette
fois ci je veux bien que vous montriez
la tendance on est à 45 % en 2014 c'est
relativement stable il ya évidemment il
ya un pic après les attentats de 2015
mais là depuis un an il ya une forte
augmentation des passes et 2 44% à
55% est-ce que vous pensez que
finalement l'abolition et en étant
d'angers sco pensée critique où j'allais
c'est terrible je vous dis qu'elle est
placée c'est effrayant que les gens
souhaitent aujourd'hui à ne pas perdre
alors que les choses ont été prouvés là
les crimes ne sont les crimes n'ont pas
augmenté de prendre une proportion
quelconque enfin si on est mieux le
terrorisme m enfin bon je vais le corps
et la science on n'a jamais réussi à
prouver on est là sur
une anse delà d'une majorité parce que
les gens sont pense qu'il est naturel de
deux condamnés à mort un certain nombre
de gens il ya un espèce de sentiment
naturel du front de choix qu'il faut
combattre en face est à ces essais de la
peine de mort est un attentat aux droits
de l'homme enfin moi j'en suis convaincu
et mai mais quand même juridiquement ça
serait aujourd'hui très difficile car
nous savons que la france a ratifié deux
protocoles internationaux
d'une part le protocole de la coupe de
la convention européenne et l'autre par
le tacle le protocole 16 le protocole de
l'ue du protocole d'état
donc il ya des protocoles tient faut
donc su avec mais bon même si un
candidat qui veut rétablir la peine de
vie prenait le pouvoir il ne peut pas je
voudrais sortir de l'union qu'est-ce
qu'il faut il faut sortir de l'union
européenne il faut attention parce que
le protocole de new york las des
nations-unies on peut pas en sortir
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas faire de
nouvelles réserves c'est impossible donc
ça veut dire que la france ce n'est fait
l'infraction d'injure et troisième point
la constitution a été modifiée c'est à
dire que l'article 66 de la constitution
aujourd'hui prévoit que la peine de mort
est abolie d'ailleurs c'est pour pouvoir
ratifier ce fameux protocole mais nous y
sommes le porte comme de numéro deux du
pacte new york que
monsieur chirac et c'était nécessaire on
a compris qu'il fallait réformer la
constitution donc il faut réformer la
constitution sur deux points
premièrement sur cet article 66 qui
décape ne m'en est abolie et
deuxièmement il faut le réformer sur un
principe fondamental que nous avons
c'est à dire que les conventions
internationales ont une valeur
supérieure et lois françaises au port je
veux bien mais j'ai entendu il ya deux
jeunes hommes un à un le pen qui le
monde me conforme la constitution bon
très bien mais enfin je ne suis pas
certain que lier quand même seulement 2
5% mais oui j'ai je vais vous donner la
parole évidemment cc courir moi on
écoute sur ces thèmes-là robert badinter
s'étaient dans une interview donnée à
public sénat ya cinq ans en ce qui
concerne le
la constitutionnalisation c'est en effet
à la fois une volonté politique commune
puisque ça dépasse les clivages de
majorité c'est un élément important
c'est moins important qu'au que les
conventions internationales
que la france a signé et qui interdisent
le recours la peine de mort si une
majorité
ce qui me paraît impossible
vois tu es le rétablissement de la peine
de mort il faut lui faudrait le
président la rapine dénoncer toutes ces
conventions est pour un état ont
présenté par un président qui toujours
le champion des droits de l'homme c'est
inconcevable
cécile courir au delà de l'aspect
juridique qu'on a bien compris et c'est
vous diriez quoi que c'est un combat
culturel social qu'il faut mener une
forme de paradoxe en france
effectivement à faire sans arrêt
ressurgir ce débat alors que comme cela
a déjà été expliqué jeffrey précise
effectivement la même année en 2007 que
ça a été constitutionnalisées en france
il y avait eu ce geste fort de signer et
ratifier ce protocole numéro deux du
pacte international relatif aux droits
civils et politiques et c'est un geste
extrêmement important pour deux raisons
c'est que non seulement ça empêche un
retour effectivement mais ça crée aussi
un effet de levier c'est à dire que
c'est là qu'on rendre au coeur du rôle
de la france que même si effectivement
elle a été seulement le 36e pays
malheureusement abolir et n'a donc pas
exactement donner l'exemple au début
nous pensons qu'aujourd'hui la france a
un rôle majeur à jouer à convaincre
d'autres états de signer et de ratifier
ce même protocole numéro deux et donc il
ya véritablement un aspect de diplomatie
française qui serait tout à son honneur
c'est pourquoi pour nous un médecin
internationale il est important de
retrouver cet élan en fait
abolitionnistes qui a et qui a porté la
france en 1981 et par la suite à cette
réaffirmation permanente et aujourd'hui
nous pensons que la france vraiment
jouer son rôle au sein de l'union
européenne puisque effectivement là
aussi un protocole au niveau du conseil
de l'europe où il ya également un
protocole et au niveau même des nations
unies et là j'en veux pour preuve que
cette résolution aux nations unies sur
le moratoire ce qui est déjà pas mal
avant l'abolition nous venons
d'atteindre l'an passé en 2020 123 le
nom de 123 états qui se sont prononcés
en faveur de ce moratoire dont ça montre
bien que dans des instants enceintes
multilatérales qu'elle soit européenne
ou d'autres d'autres régions du monde
bien sûr y'a pas que l'europe mais aussi
au niveau multilatéral onu ça a vraiment
un effet de levier un effet domino
positif que de montrer que cet
engagement international va même au delà
de celui qu'on a pris en tant qu'etat au
sein même de la france seulement mathieu
c'est un sujet qui est clivant
politiquement parlant quand on regarde
les sondages en gros les partisans du
rétablissement de la peine de mort sont
plutôt les partisans du rassemblement
national ou de la droite et les oppose
les opposants on y trouve plutôt chez
les électeurs de madame mâcon et celle à
gauche mais c'est un sujet car quand
même disparu du champ du débat politique
le front national qui était un des
partis elle a proposé de rétablissement
de la peine de mort le plus tard voilà
la vigne par l'abandonner avec marine le
pen qui a dit qu'elle était peut-être
pour
pour des raisons personnelles mais en
tout cas elle ne le porterai pas mais
que peut-être des citoyens pouvaient par
le biais d'un référendum populaire si
jamais été mis en place
c'est pierre sancan
dès d'aujourd'hui alors le dernier est
un terreau de fib le candidat le dernier
à avoir été interrogé sur la question
c'est eric zemmour qui qu'alors que ça
faisait pas partie de ces propositions
il a été interrogé sur cette question là
il est dit que ce n'était pas une
priorité mais que personnellement il
était pauvre
il fallait osé employer le mot
philosophiquement à côté du fn qui est
la négation même on se demande mais de
toute civilisation
donc effectivement flatter les instincts
les plus bas de deux personnes qui
parfois sont avant tout aux prises avec
la peur finalement je pense que dans
l'histoire monsieur vous avez vous aussi
de nombreux exemples ce sont des faits
divers ou des faits atroces comme vous
le disiez à l'instant est aujourd'hui
également la peur du terrorisme qui fait
que parfois les personnes ont
l'impression que ce serait une solution
donc c'est très important qu'on fasse ce
travail au long cours sans considérer
que c'est acquis même si ces acquis
juridiquement sur le plan des mentalités
me semble essentiel continue ce qu'on
appelle l'éducation aux droits humains
de toutes les façons possibles avec
comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure le film
l'interview badinter part amnesty france
mais je pense aussi à un documentaire
dans le cas de monsieur leclerc apparaît
également tout comme moi qui s'intitule
le des gueules d'assassins fait par le
barreau de lille et ça c'est l'avant
première demain donc je tenais justement
alain on sait parce que je pense que ce
genre de film a un rôle majeur à jouer
pour la prise de conscience à la fois du
fait que ce serait totalement
désespérant que de revenir en arrière
mais aussi que c'est un combat qu'il
faut continuer à mener jusqu'à
l'abolition universelle et en ayant le
courage de regarder en face nos
contradictions c'est à dire par rapport
justement au aux menaces terroristes par
rapport aux faits divers par rapport au
fait que l'émotion trop souvent bloque
la réflexion finalement temps je trouve
que ces documentaires justement des
vrais gones assassin qui a une citation
de badinter n'a encore d'ailleurs montre
très bien la façon dont la france et
tout temps pris dans ses contradictions
et à quel point il était important
d'avoir un discours politique fort bruno
fini sur le marqueur politique dont
parle et matthieu croissandeau il y à il
y a eu des abolitionnistes de droite oui
il ya eu d'abord dents chez les
gaullistes chez les démocrates chrétiens
il ya eu des abolitionnistes dans le lui
dirai dans le camp conservateur en
particulier pour des raisons religieuses
avec l'idée que l'homme n'avait pas le
droit de retirer la vie à un autre homme
et ce courant là a pu s'allier avec un
courant beaucoup plus humaniste laïque
eu plus ancré à gauche et on a pu avoir
des rapprochements comme cela surtout
après la seconde guerre mondiale ou des
démocrates chrétiens et des hommes de
gauche s'étaient fréquentés alliés
également dans les mouvements de
résistance dont il ya eu des
rapprochements en fait le vrai clivage y
tient à la conception qu'on a de l'être
humain et ça c'est très frappant dans
les débats du 19e et du début du 20e
siècle les partisans de la peine de mort
en fait c'est des gens qui sont un petit
peu avec l'anthropologie criminelle de
lombroso qui considère qu'il ya des
criminels né il ya des personnes qui ne
changeront jamais qui sont destinés à
être criminel c'est la même idée qu'on a
parfois qu'on pourrait deviner à
l'avance dès l'enfance si quelqu'un sera
un criminel il ya une théorie un petit
peu de la fatalité c'est ce que dénonce
et jaurès c'est ce qu'affirme et barrès
le nationaliste qui disait voilà il ya
des individus qui sont dégénéré rien à
en tirer il n'y a rien à en attendre
alors qu un abolitionniste vous dire à
ce criminel dont je ne nie pas qu'il a
tué pourra en prison et bien prendre
conscience de la gravité de son acte et
pourra d'une manière ou d'une autre
évoluer un chrétien dire à se racheter
un humaniste aura une autre démarche
mais à l'idée d'une plasticité de l'être
humain yal'idée aussi que qu'énoncées
jaurès d'une responsabilité sociale du
trim dans le crime c'est-à-dire qu'un
criminel est-ce que c'est simplement un
individu qui tue ou est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui dans un contexte social et
ce qui met en cause la responsabilité de
tout le monde la nôtre celle des
pouvoirs publics celle de l'ensemble des
citoyens eh bien il va être poussé à
tuer si on regarde par exemple la liste
des personnes qui ont été effectivement
guillotiné ce sont essentiellement des
hommes jeunes et issus de milieux plutôt
pauvre voire carrément misérable donc on
voit bien qu'il ya un bien énorme
sociologique alors c'est ce que disait
jusqu'ici m pas bon je veux dire que
c'est les gens de droite c'est vrai donc
dans le grand débat de 1908 yade
abbé-lemire par exemple qui souligne que
l'autodafé magnifique et et
nous savons que jacques chirac était
courageux parce que c'était quand même
contre eux l'opinion majoritaire est
majoritaire sans doute de ceux qui
voteraient pour lui mais il ya eu
d'autres hommes droite basse sous le bon
mais moi j'ai connu je veux me raconter
j'ai connu j'ai rencontré un homme avec
lequel j'ai parlé un jour très qui était
un ministre le touchent entre m'en fasse
entendre son bonus petit plus petit un
jour m'a raconté il l'a raconté à lire
ménard a contraint une chose
extraordinaire après l'arrestation des
leaders de la résistance et et
l'assassinât de jean moulin enfin bon
choix torture il a été chargé par le
groupe qui était de tuer
rené hardy dont il pensait que c'était
lui qui avait de dénoncer et dinan ces
gens là et il n'a pas réussi et il est
venu témoigner au procès de rené hardy
qu'on a fait après qu'elles eurent été
acquitté deux fois
mais il est venu témoigner et il a dit
voyez j'étais pour le vhc c'était un
acte de guerre c'était un acte de guerre
aujourd'hui je vous demande de ne pas
condamner à mort quoi qu'il ait fait
beau je suis convaincu que les coupes
mais il faut pas le condamner à mort
voilà et ça je trouve que c'est très
caractéristique d'une pensée de droite
aussi c'est à dire les gens qui pensent
que pays il ya quatre conscience on peut
pas condamner à mort quelqu'un qui est
vivant
sur le vous évoquez les inégalités
sociales on écoute robert badinter c'est
un autre extrait du document vous nous
avez fourni
moi je n'ai jamais vu
un fils ou une fille de banquiers
américains
tant pis si l'ue l'écran de leur bord
mais
le plus infortunés des noirs des états
unis pour les comtés en nombre le
racisme peuple des cellules
inégalités sociales et lili éviter
culturelle inédite et des richesses
entre les pays tout se joue et derrière
le masque de justice en réalité c'est
tous les préjugés et c'est tous les
poisons d'une société c'est mr tessi
coudriou il nous parle des états unis
mais pas seulement c'est vrai que on
pense souvent aux etats unis quand on
pense à quel point cette peine est
discriminatoire c'est ça a été vraiment
démontré par des statistiques c'est
absolument à dire indéniable que les
minorités ethniques mais aussi les
pauvres sont dramatiquement plus touchés
par cette peine que d'autres pour
beaucoup de raisons notamment le fait
que parfois un simple de témoignages
oculaires suffit à
à condamner quelqu'un à mort est
d'ailleurs l'un de mes pires souvenirs
j'en parle dans ce documentaire de
l'assassin c'est celui de troy davis un
citoyen noir américain qui a été
condamné en absence totale de preuves
factuelles c'était simplement des outils
et compris personnes qui se sont
rétractés par la suite et donc c'est
malgré tout la mobilisation mondiale
c'est vraiment le un contre exemple
heureusement que bien souvent on a sauvé
la vie de condamnés à mort mais pour
celui ci c'est reste effectivement
impossible et vous avez raison de dire
ça n'est pas qu'aux états unis c'est à
l'échelle mondiale notamment on voit en
iran où il ya énormément d'exécution lié
à la drogue ou ce sont bien sûr des
personnes très souvent totalement
désespéré qui n'ont aucun aucun moyen de
s'en sortir et au lieu de les aider ils
sont en fait qu'on années dans des
prisons absolument ils monde et donc il
y a effectivement non seulement cet
aspect totalement injuste de la peine de
mort parce qu'on prétend être certain
qu'il ya toujours ce risque de l'erreur
judiciaire
et là aussi il ya beaucoup de
démonstrations qui ont été faites d'une
incroyable notamment aux états unis mais
pas seulement le
pardon est notamment grâce à l'adn
exactement
ses internationaux fectivement utilise
aussi beaucoup cet argument ce que tous
les arguments il faut en fait les
longues montées 5e je parlais de cette
éducation aux droits humains de
sensibilisation que ce soit à travers un
film à travers des jeux de rôle à
travers toutes sortes d'activités y
compris dans la rue des événements des
happenings tout peut en fait briser
cette impression un peu facile
finalement que c'est une solution c'est
ce bois du taillon combat social et
culturel dont on parlait tout à l'heure
c'est vrai mais le l'argument de
l'erreur judiciaire est évidemment
primordial mais en même temps il ne
suffit pas là vous avez raison
philosophique c'est ce que j'ai défendue
qui risque la peine de mort était
coupable ces coupables yahia ya pas de
doute le problème était donc le principe
même de la peine de mort et est bon
c'est bon ce que j'veux qu'on dit
effectivement sur le fait que c'est des
pauvres là le discours de jaurès sur
celui de discours ou ge et qui dit le
ton le monde nouveau ne passera pas face
au formidable mais en même temps c'est
vrai que ce que moi j'ai défendu
d'ailleurs qui risque la peine de mort
c'était tous des les gens dans une
situation poupe sociale difficile
ceci étant c'est vrai l'ensemble des
réponses elle met particulièrement
effectivement la dea et c'est vrai que
le discours de jaurès me paraît
aujourd'hui toujours essentiel il
fallait quand même nous prenons et un
mot qu'il faut prononcer ses suites
victorieux au cadre vraiment le combat
de victor hugo pendant toute sa vie ou
sa vie debout peter nouveaux
intervenants pourrait s'être sauvé
maximilien qui était l'envoyé de
robespierre ou au mexique enfin c'était
de l'anxiété juste le contraire de 2
double robespierre près de naples et
l'envoyé de napoléon iii et mexique
c'était c'était terrible c'est ce combat
les mots de victor hugo la force de
victor hugo doivent être saluées
lamartine aussi d'ailleurs mais et dans
le cas de victor hugo ce ne sont pas
seulement des mots c'est à dire qu'à
l'époque où par exemple ils siègent ars
qui ne s'appelle pas encore le sénat et
la chambre des pairs c'est donc un
personnage important déjà dans le régime
sous la monarchie de juillet il invente
le droit de visite des parlementaires
c'est à dire que lorsqu'il ya un
condamné à paris il va là où il est
détenu avant l'exécution il va les voir
il va les rencontrer il va parler à
certains d'eux est donc dans ses carnets
on a des récits de rencontres et de
discussions avec des hommes qui sont
voués à mourir donc il est allé très
très loin dans le travail sur
l'abolition est à dire qu il ya eu des
écrits il ya eu des discours et alors ce
qui est remarquable a tout à fait raison
m c'est que vittorio a beaucoup varié au
cours de sa carrière il a été royaliste
il a été républicain il a été socialiste
mais sur la peine de mort il a toujours
été contre et pour
deux raisons effectivement bon le risque
de l'erreur judiciaire mais c'était pas
fondamental c'était un combat de
civilisation pour lui et puis cet
argument aussi qui résonne dans le
discours de 1848 que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure c'est que l'irrévocable
l'irréparable et lundi soluble ça
n'appartient pas à l'homme lui croyait
en dieu disait voilà ils sont trois
choses qui appartiennent à dieu qui
n'appartiennent pas à l'homme à l'heure
à l'homme si les introduit dans ses lois
il arrive alors que la loi épouvante la
conscience je cite de mémoire les mots
sont très forts mais c'est vrai que la
peine de mort par nature c'est
irrévocable irréparable indissoluble et
là ce sont peut-être les limites de la
loi de la législation humaine il emploie
les termes morale universelle d'ailleurs
qui est un terme très moderne je trouve
ma morale universelle et ça renvoie la
question de l'abolition universelle que
vous défendez évidemment avec un essai
international on a cherché démocratie
qui pratiquent au nom du terme encore la
peine de mort évidemment les états unis
l'inde le japon l'inde et jaton l'egypte
le liban singapour taïwan est-ce que
c'est vers ces pays qu'à vous ai fait
réciter en démocratie mais les tyrannies
aloyse oui mais c'est parce que c'est
peut-être mais comprenez pourquoi je le
fais m dans une démocratie c'est
peut-être là que qu'il faut mener le
combat je voudrais pouvoir répondre
effectivement à cela parce que dans le
travail de plaidoyer que nous menons
auprès des autorités et qu'encore une
fois nous demandons aussi à la france de
mener beaucoup de force cette année il
ya effectivement c'est une sorte de
stratégie de pas à pas ça par exemple
une démocratie comme les états unis on a
effectivement gagné et un après on en
est aujourd'hui à 22 donc c'est encore
un sacré chemin à parcourir mais malgré
tout le fait que ce soit la virginie
dernier état qui est abolie et tout un
symbole car c'est une première et à du
sud pendant une tradition séculaire de
d'attachement cette peine de mort et
dans d'autres pays comme par exemple
inde ou le japon qui surtout l'inde qui
veut avoir une place sur la scène
internationale et se montrer comme une
vraie démocratie et bien c'est la partie
en fait des effets de levier dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
et c'est pourquoi la stratégie et pas à
pas dans tous les sens du terme c'est à
dire aussi pour revenir à mon argument
précédent lorsque vous avez un pays
comme par exemple l'arabie saoudite donc
c'est très bien que c'est l'un des pays
les plus grands exécuteur les pierres
exécuteur est très difficile à faire
changer d'avis eh bien parfois c'est en
réduisant le nombre de crimes qui sera
passible de la peine de mort que nous
pouvons au moins sauver des vies par
exemple en 2020 certainement en lien
avec le sommet de g20 que préside l
arabie saoudite si l'on décidé s'est pas
encore passé dans la loi mais en tout
cas ça a été annoncé que les mineurs ne
ferait plus l'objet de châtiment donc de
la peine de mort donc parfois c'est
aussi pas à pas dans dans la mentalité
c'est pourquoi je parlais tout à l'heure
de l'innocence potentiel car même si
pour nous l'abolition est véritablement
notre objectif en toutes circonstances
on est contre la peine de mort nous
savons très bien que pour convaincre on
peut commencer par dire tout de même
elles sont condamnées à mort pour
homosexualité pour blasphème et même des
gens qui sont pour la peine de mort
commence un petit peu à bouger je sais
pourquoi ce travail à la fois de
plaidoyer et de sensibilisation auprès
des citoyens cette fois et non pas
auprès des autorités est menée en
parallèle car nous savons que si nous
arrivons à gagner à notre cause étape
par étape ses personnels vont à leur
tour peut-être se mobiliser auprès de
leurs autorités et il y aura un effet
finalement un cercle vertueux vers
l'abolition rappelons parce que j'ai pas
prendre trop de temps dans le tout de
même qu'en amnesty internationl a
commencé ce combat en 1977 il n'y avait
que 16 états qui avait aboli ils sont
aujourd'hui 108 pour tous les crimes
plus encore 28 pour le fait de l'avoir
aboli en tout cas en pratique on arrive
à 144 pays en tout qui ne pratiquent
plus de manière active la peine de mort
dont qu'il en reste 50 5 si je compte
bien à convaincre et c'est vraiment
atteignable puisque justement on
s'aperçoit que avec cet effet donc de de
dominos finalement le cercle vertueux de
plus en plus de payer se rendre compte
ça devient inacceptable sur une scène
internationale de pratiquer encore des
peines telles que la décapitation
houleux ou la pendaison jeu devra
commencer aux etats unis quand même pris
parce que moi je boive lui a vu dans
l'est dans les débats que j'ai eu avec
certains pays bas c'était toujours la
même chose enfin les états unis
s'exécute bien et il faut se battre
toujours pour dire mon bassin les étages
aurait il ya mouvement abolitionniste
fort autres effaré j'ai eu des contacts
avec des avocats américains très
courageuse et mais c'est très dur quand
même c'est les états unis c'est un
mauvais exemple
voilà c'est ce que je peux dire les
autres et sous les gens disent l'arabie
saoudite et l'iran
également des pays en afrique qui ont
vraiment suivi ce chemin on arrive
maintenant à 22 états sur le continent
africain qui ont pas de jupe on oblige
la chine ne sais pas combien la chine
exactement c'est un secret d'état donc
en fait on sait ce sont des milliers
mais amnesty international dans son
rapport qu'il publie chaque année fait
nous publions chaque année a décidé
d'enlever en fait la chine tellement on
savait très bien qu avait des d
instrumentalisation de nos chiffres
parce qu'ils sont en fait impossible à
vérifier nous avons enlevé la chine mais
en tout cas ce les statistiques montrent
que ça avance dans le bon sens vers
l'abolition universelle coup merci à
tous les quatre merci beaucoup d'être
venu sur le plateau de sens public je
vous donne rendez vous demain et